looks like somebody want some of that
New Hampshire Spotlight California
governor Gavin new some going on Bill
marah show to attack Republicans and
call out his own party for not being
tough enough on the
GOP the reason I started to go into
those red States the reason I started to
take on to santis and the reason I
started doing ads in these red States is
I didn't felt my party was doing enough
it was CRT one year and then it's ESG
and it's Dei anything with three letters
these guys keep coming and I just felt
there was a little timidity in our party
and I thought we need to call this stuff
out but Bill Maher wasn't ready to let
Governor Newsome off the hook on whether
Newsome has been running a secret
campaign for president I was a
lieutenant governor and you have me on I
mean who has Lieutenant Governors on
that's amazing abely and I said then
you're going to run for president one
day and and we know it's not this
year I'm not going to even go there oh
no I'm glad we're not going I'm
not it's not bad he's thinking about the
presidency uh Greg uh in a couple years
and I think I think he's right what do
you think about him I think he's watched
American Psycho too many times I mean
Christian Bale has nothing on this guy
he's like the rich kid buttering up his
dying Uncle as he waits for him to croak
he's out in the hallway clutching a my
pillow the moment the nurse leaves he's
putting it down on Joe uh and then he
makes this he talks about like he makes
this weird comment about uh DeSantis you
know about Dei ESG and CRT what he fails
to mention is that Gavin Newsome was
wrong on all of that and DeSantis was
right on all those threel entities about
how that how they are helping to destroy
a company by going after a country by
going after equal opportunity in
meritocracy you know now we we even have
Dems admitting that Reverse Racism is
actually racism and I know he jokes
about Dan santis but at least Dan santis
is running for for the office in public
you know not sneaking around like a
political cat burglar Dana uh would you
advise Governor Nome to do what he's
doing or would you have a different uh
set of advice for him I don't think he
will ever take my advice I would
actually think that he should focus on
his own State you know last year they
ended up with a $97 billion Surplus a
lot of that was all that covid money
this year they have a 73 billion deficit
how do you do that right and so I think
that it's fed it was fedman actually who
said said go to the bathroom or get off
the pot if you're going to run run and
then Bill Maher is like making fun of
Joe Biden kind of saying obviously the
cognitive capabilities are in question
and Nome just laughs along so he does
seem to be playing this a little bit too
cute by half judge what are your
thoughts on this I agree with Dana I
think it's too cute by half I think it's
the old wink and the nod and no I'm not
really running this year and you know
it's interesting the way he he kind of
categorizes a division between the red
States and the blue States oh you know
they just weren't they they weren't
strong enough when he's very you know
divisive it's them versus us and you
know how he gloated when Ronda santis
got out of the race with you know
there's a fire sale on Ronda santis
merch today you know at least as you say
I mean Ronda santz got in the race and
Gavin Nome is being very very sneaky
about it I don't know what's going on
and you know he says he's doing it
because he believes in women's rights
well if you believe in women's rights
why are you allowing transgenders you
know to ruin a lot of women's hopes and
dreams and you can say that the governor
before you created that law but you've
done nothing to protect young women so
you know he's a lot of all hat no cattle
I think Dana oh I like that one all
moose and no hair you know I'm with Dana
go to the bathroom or get off the pot
yeah uh Jesse of all of us on the five
including Jessica one would say you look
the most like Gavin Nome what what are
your thoughts about uh Governor Nome
well I'm going to consider that a
compliment Jessica so thank you very
much and you're not showing your
pregnancy at all I think you look really
fit thank you thank you I I would say
that Biden's kind of in a long-distance
relationship with the Democratic party
and Nome keeps showing up when Biden's
out of town you know all of a sudden
like he's at her field hockey game then
all of a sudden he's at the orchard when
she's apple picking with her friend
just the right amount of proximity to
let her know that he's there whoa wait a
second he's in China oh he's on Bill Mah
the Sunday before that primary Greg's
right disantis could have cat burglar it
too he could have been like I'm gonna
take Casey to DC for dinner and you know
maybe go to the Tampa Bay Bucks down
shoot shoot down to Mexico City to just
happen to meet the Mexican president
yeah either way I think
works well he's doing something right
coming up bad guys beware America's Most
Wanted is coming back to Fox and John
Walsh his son Callan join us next hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaylee
mechineni on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 pm Eastern or set your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights